a Las Vegas mother searches for her
daughter and turns to tick tock for help
now the FBI is involved 8 news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy has been
working to find answers today about this
missing person's case which has
certainly a lot of twists and turns the
mother of zaylee Flores says she last
heard from her daughter 19 days ago she
says she believes she's in trouble and
now she and the FBI are asking for the
Public's help
and I'm trying
um sorry
to be strong for use daily but I don't
know where you're at April reads message
to her daughter's daily Flores the
mother's posts on Tick Tock about zaly's
disappearance have gone viral my 21 year
old daughter is missing she is in
Tijuana Mexico April says she last heard
from zaly by phone on January 12th and
she said she was in Mexico and sounded
incoherent this is wrong
on every level she's only 21. she says
she was contacted with the demand for
ransom 500 and when she asked for a
photo of her daughter for proof of life
that was never provided then there's
this man who in messages with the 8 news
now investigators claims he was zaily's
boyfriend since December they moved from
California to Mexico and he last saw her
in Tijuana on January 11th what do you
think are the possibilities here because
there are many possibilities
I have to live with the truth of
there's a possibility that she may not
be living there's a possibility that
he knows where she is and he's not
saying anything
or she just may be out in Mexico doing
whatever she may not even be in Mexico
at all I don't I don't know where my
baby is I have no clue but I'm not going
to stop looking for her she says daily
has had struggles with mental health and
drug abuse she was reportedly accused of
stealing a car in 2021 while the FBI is
now investigating this missing person's
case April says she just wants to know
her daughter is safe if you have kids
stop what you're doing and give them a
hug because
there's nothing like a feeling of not
being able to do that so and if somebody
really has her
give her back Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now